et pour cette recette notre duo du jour
c'est romain grâce aux le chef et son
élève clarisse charpentier donc
aujourd'hui nous sommes en train de
préparer une ballottine de saumon frais
à l'aneth avec une salade de courgettes
cru mariné aux agrumes avec du citron
noir d'iran dessus donc pour cette
recette vous avons préparé une farce
qu'on appelle une farce mousseline donc
avec du saumon frais qui sera taillant
au cube des blancs d'oeuf de la crème
liquide et de l'âne est haché à
l'intérieur donc cette ballottine nous
allons la rouler dans du film avant de
la cuire dans un four vapeur donc j'ai
ma farce qui a été fixé et qui est prête
dans une poche à douille
donc je vais mettre ma farce dans le
film et ensuite je vais venir former à
l'aide du papier film des petits
rouleaux en serrant bien sur les côtés
[Musique]
et donc ça on va les mettre à cuire soit
dans une casserole d'eau chaude ou dans
un cuiseur vapeur environ 80 degrés moi
je m'occupe de la fed de courgettes
donc je passe lama courgettes à la
mandoline et je vais juste prélever la
peau on va ensuite mettre nos courgettes
dans un petit saladier on va venir
ajouter toutes nos herbes aromatiques
donc on va mettre un petit peu de
ciboulette
un petit peu de coriandre légèrement
parce que la coriandre cinq ans même
tendance à m'emporter un peu le plat des
noisettes
un peu d'aneth pour rappeler l'herbe
qu'on a mis dans les dents le saunier on
va mettre
tout citron vert donc doucement si vite
et un peu de segments d'orange on peut
mettre un petit peu le jeu aussi et donc
un petit peu d'huile de noix
on va pouvoir tout mettre dans le fond
de l'assiette
on note ballottine de ce monde ont été
cuites on la sort du four vapeur et on
va venir légèrement tailler les entament
donc on voit on a quand même un produit
qui est bien ferme
[Musique]
donc on peut la taille et en deux pour
un petit côté esthétique on peut la
laisser entière aussi tout dépend et
donc on va venir déposer notre
ballottine sur notre petite salade de
courgettes donc on a fait réduire notre
jus d'orange notre jus de citron on a
mis un petit peu de crème et ensuite on
à monter au beurre donc à l'aide d'un
fouet on a monté on a fait une sauce un
peu le principe du beurre blanc en fait
mais avec des agrumes dessus et donc on
va venir après nappes et notre santé
notre poisson
[Musique]
et à la fin on va venir pour amener un
petit peu de déco pour un petit côté un
peu végétal on va venir disposer des
petites peluches de cerfeuil comme ça on
va venir rap est donc un citron noir qui
a été séché et fumer donc ces
spécialités de lire en fête c'est du
citron noire d'hier en est là c'est un
agrume qui est vraiment très puissant
puisque on va avoir un côté très boisé
un côté très très fumée et ça va venir
sublimer un petit peu notre notre plat
et va merci à tous les deux dans merci
la vie ce merci maman il nous reste plus
qu'à déguster